let me ask you this in that same vein we
we actually go to the other side instead
of having a budget we're not concerned
about the budget we're concerned about
our credit score now you alluded to this
a moment ago and one of the things that
you you you you said in your book you
talked about the FICO score right I love
that breakdown of wood yeah it's funny
we I was I was doing a YouTube video and
talking about the three people who'd be
on the road with us and I brought your
book up and I read that little excerpt
in there about the FICO score and the
person who commented was like this
Anthony guys clearly naive everyone
needs to have a great credit score I'm
not even yeah why are they wrong well
here's the thing I don't have a credit
score and and this is why it's because I
said this earlier that a credit score it
literally only tells you how much debt
you have how often you're paying back
your debt what kind of debt you have
what's the likelihood of you getting
more debt so when we look at a credit
score our credit score rewards us for
debt and that it's not freedom so if you
have an 800 credit score it just simply
means you love if you have a zero credit
score it means that you love cash and
you're patient to buy the things with
your money and so I'm not saying that a
credit score is your just a horrible
individual for me in my house what I
believe is I'm going to pay for
everything and I'm going to own
everything that I have not the banks and
so for an example a lot of people say
well you have to have a credit score to
buy a house well you don't I just built
my dream home it's a little bit bigger
than what you know that yeah anyways um
we don't judgment okay thank you so much
no we don't have shame there we go yes
so I built my dream home it's a nice
house anyways you can you use every
single piece of Amman don't put don't
sell yourself short no I mean but no
listen I was building my house while
watching you all show and say you know
what I went back to my architect scratch
it all let's do this thing again because
I don't need it but dining-room it's
just me bro
do I really need a dining room No so um
really I I did the right thing but what
I'm saying is this I didn't need a
credit score see my there's this thing
called underwriting and what they
manually would underwrite your mortgage
payment cuz I did finance my home I put
down 50% i financed the other 50% for 10
years and and it's literally a fixed
rate and so my goal is paid off in five
because I don't like debt and that's the
only thing that we say okay we're cool
with but I don't need a credit score for
that then lot of people said well you
need a credit score for an or rental
company well I rented a car to drive up
here today to come be with you all and I
did it with my debit card here's the
downfall that a lot of people say
without a credit score you're gonna move
slow and absolutely right but you know
what I don't have a problem with moving
slow I Drive a car right now that's 100
and has 170 thousand miles on it
it works and it is beautiful and whoever
I get married it's nothing to deal with
it because the engines knocking a little
bit but it's paid for and at least we
knocking on our front door of the house
you know and so a credit score no it is
it's not needed I've never ran into a
situation where I couldn't get what I
wanted because I didn't have a credit
score now are there certain people who
would not finance you oh absolutely
but why do you need financing if you're
gonna do everything cash all of my
mentors are completely debt free and I
have mentors who are millionaires and I
have mentors who are just making six
figures and I also have mentors who are
pastors who are not making six figures
and none of them have a credit score but
I do tell you I can't tell you there's
one thing that all of them have is a
peace of mind in knowing that you know
what I own every single thing that I
have and if I can't pay for it cash I'm
gonna wait until I can
you